Pusimos los electrodos para poder grabar de las neuronas
que conectan los ojos con las alas.
Cada vez que se envía un mensaje del ojo al ala,
el electrodo intercepta esa conversación
en forma de corriente eléctrica
y la amplifica.
Ahora podemos escucharla y verla en la forma de pico,
que también se llama una potencia activa.
Escuchémosla.
En este momento tenemos a la libélula boca abajo,
entonces está mirando hacia el suelo.
Tomamos una presa o lo que a veces llamamos un blanco.
En este caso, el blanco es una mosca falsa.
La movemos hasta estar a la vista de la libélula.
(Zumbido)
¡Oh!
¡Mira eso!
Mira eso. Pero solo ocurre con una dirección.
¡Sí!
No se ve ningún pico cuando voy para adelante,
pero están allí cuando voy para atrás.
En nuestros experimentos,
pudimos ver que las neuronas de la libélula dispararon
cuando movimos el punto en una dirección, pero no en la otra.
¿Por qué pasó así?
¿Recuerdas cuando dije que la libélula tiene la visión de casi 360 grados?
Hay una sección del ojo llamada la fóvea
y esta es la parte con la mayor agudeza visual.
Piénsalo como su punto de mira.
¿Recuerdas cuando dije que la libélula tiene el control individual de sus alas?
Cuando una libélula ve a su presa, apunta su punto de mira hacia ella
y a través de sus axones, envía mensajes solo a las neuronas
que controlan las partes de las alas que se necesitan
para guiar a la libélula al blanco.
Entonces si la presa está a la izquierda de la libélula,
solo se disparan las neuronas que tiran de las alas a la izquierda.
Y si la presa se mueve a la derecha de la libélula,
esas mismas neuronas ya no se necesitan y se quedan inactivas.
La libélula corre hacia la presa a un ángulo fijo
que se comunica por este punto a las alas,
y luego -¡boom!- la cena.
Todo esto ocurre en un instante, y sin esfuerzo por parte de la libélula.
Es casi como un reflejo.
Este proceso increíblemente eficaz se llama fijación.
Pero hay algo más en este proceso.
Vimos cómo las neuronas respondieron a los movimientos,
pero ¿cómo sabe la libélula que algo sí es presa?
Aquí el tamaño importa.
Mostrémosle a la libélula una serie de puntos.
¡Sí!
JS: Sí, prefiere ese.
GG: De todos los tamaños,
encontramos que la libélula respondió a los objetos pequeños
más que a los grandes.
Es decir, que la libélula está programada para perseguir moscas más pequeñas
versus algo mucho más grande,
como un pájaro.
Y tan pronto como identifique algo como la presa,
a esa pobrecita mosca, solo le quedan segundos de vida.
Hoy vimos cómo funciona el cerebro de la libélula
y que eso la convierte en un depredador muy eficaz.
Agradezcamos que no vivimos hace 300 millones de años,
cuando las libélulas eran del tamaño de los gatos.